the Irish novelist Cecilia her made her
debut in the publishing world with PS I
love you back in 2004 15 books later we
get to her newest is titled raw in its
collection of 30 short stories about 30
women who are at pivotal points in their
lives I caught up with her over
breakfast where she started off by
telling me about her initial struggle to
get this book published for the last
five years I wasn't sure if there was
going to be a place in the publishing
world for them because I always write
novels and so I just kept writing for
myself but I was also trying to get them
made for as a TV series and the
excitement that I was getting from
friends was very different to what I was
receiving in the pit room and but what
happened was a January of last year I
went over to LA to do some pitching for
TV about totally different ideas and
they said to me well what are you most
about at the moment and I started
talking about these stories and
immediately the air changed in the room
you know people women were crying we
were laughing we were sharing stories
and I think I think what happened is
that a Trump was inaugurated that week
and the women's March was due to take
place that weekend and so emotions are
really heightened people were fearful
they were sad but they were also wanted
to take action and started telling more
women stories so the timing wasn't right
five years ago but it was it's
absolutely right now it's that wonderful
quote I am woman hear me roar and what's
the story in this book that particularly
resonates with you what makes you wrong
oh all 30 of those you know one one
story that was that really resonates
with me is the guilt story so the woman
who found bite marks on her skin and as
a young is a mother returning to work
after maternity leave and she finds
these white marks all over her skin they
grow by day and she realizes that the
guilt is eating her alive now you don't
just have to have children to feel guilt
I think as women we were just made of
you know not all women but many of us
are made of guilt and feel it so easily
it's on the surface all the time we have
we have so many different relationships
with people that with people in our
lives we have to be so many different
people and I think we often feel guilty
that we're not being enough to all of
those people in our lives so I kind of
that's a special one to me I can relate
to and I the day I wrote it I'm
relieving my child at home who cried you
know as I was leaving highest brought my
daughter to Montessori cried as I left
her and I just sat him to my car in
cries and that was the day I wrote that
story obviously in Ireland there was the
big abortion debate yeah was that an
undercurrent when you were writing yeah
it was actually and oh god I mean it's
been such a sensitive topic for so long
in Ireland for so very long not just
leading up to the referendum but I was
also and so there was huge debate and
huge discussion and and so much of it
just by man you know and I remember
sitting there and listening to men
talking about women's bodies and
thinking where is the female voice you
know of course men are entitles their
opinion but we are too and so that story
it's about a man who tries to have a
vasectomy but he has to sit with a panel
of women who have a say and control over
his body and I just wanted to flip you
know I just wanted to flip the story and
and change the perspective there is no
area really where a man doesn't have
control over his own body there isn't
and that and that was just amazed as you
said I'm not an activist but that is my
way of kind of processing what's going
on and saying well if we reverse this
how much sense does it make it doesn't
make sense at all it's interesting isn't
it because obviously for those of you
who don't know you're certainly does
give it away but your father's utter
you're heard and when people was talk
about issues being politicized do you
think they missed the point a bit
because politics is just people talking
about the issues that affect people
every day
you sound like my dad I grew up but do
you think he used to always say was
politics is about people that's what
politics is it's about those everyday
issues and you know he was an absolute
workaholic so whenever I was with him he
was constantly working and I was seeing
people would always approach him and he
would always have his little notebook
and pen in his pocket I'm write down
what they're saying and so and that was
at my understanding at politics you know
that direct contact with people and
trying to better their lives he were 21
when your uh 'bless PS I love you huge
global success and with that came a bit
of ageism mmm no what was your
experience of that because you know
being a young successful man can often
be seen
that lead to being a young successful
woman it certainly did and a 21 people
were questioning whether I wrote it did
my dad get me the deal I've did my mom
Rice's and I was you know it was a big
secret that I was promoting it there was
all kind of odd conspiracy theories but
but data size people were questioning at
21 what experience of life do you have
and how can you write these stories I
would always explain you know from the
moment were born were filled we feel you
know children feel deeply and also as an
author the job is to be empathetic you
know and to have imagination and and mix
those things together in order to be
able to write a story so a lot of it was
so focused on my age and whether I
deserved it I felt like I always had to
justify my success and say I know this
doesn't always happen and I'm almost I'm
very sorry that has happened and I know
I broke the rule and yeah so for a long
time I felt like I was like that but not
anymore oh what's your next big venture
what are you gonna tackle next in your
writing in my writing well I'm almost
I'm a final edit stages of my next novel
so and my brief to myself was this is
not the thirty-first story of roar I
like to with each novel I like to move
in a different direction change the tone
changed character change the story so
I've gone very different again in
another direction well let's put a date
in the diary for breakfast this time
next year deal to talk about really
lovely to see you thank you so much
thank you so much